Narrator: Warner Bros. released
the first trailer for "Joker,"
an origin story about
Batman's most famous foe,
starring Joaquin Phoenix.
There's a lot of references to movies
and the original comic books alike.
Here's everything you might have missed.
In the first shot, we see Arthur
Fleck, not in clown makeup,
meeting with a social
worker named Debra Kane.
Kane was also featured in the comic
"Batman: The Ultimate Evil."
Bruce Wayne uses her as an informant
to investigate a pedophile ring.
We see Fleck sitting in a room
working on a sheet of jokes.
As we see later in the trailer,
this Joker is an aspiring comedian.
In the Batman story "The Killing Joke,"
The Joker is also portrayed
as a struggling stand-up comedian.
The Joker: I got nervous
and blew a punchline.
Narrator: If you take a
close look at the notebook,
you can see that The Joker's material
pulls from his real life.
There's references to mental illness,
insomnia, and poverty.
It's important to note that
this is a comic book movie
heavily inspired not just
by the source material,
but also by a lot of movies.
The filmmakers have stated
that their intention
was not just to make a DC movie
but rather one that looks a lot like
a Martin Scorsese movie.
The movie is set in Gotham in 1981,
and the look of it seems pulled from
the 1970s and 1980s New
York, as you can see
from the shots of the street,
the cars, and the subway.
Martin Scorsese's 1976
masterpiece, "Taxi Driver,"
also takes place in this setting.
In the movie, Robert De Niro plays
insomnia-stricken Vietnam
war veteran Travis Bickle,
who rides the city streets at night
and plunges into unimaginable darkness.
In one of the movie's most
famous lines, Bickle says,
Travis Bickle: There's no escape.
I am God's lonely man.
Narrator: Warner Bros. described "Joker"
as an exploration of a
man disregarded by society
that is not only a character study
but also a broader cautionary tale.
This scene with Arthur on a date
is also reminiscent of
Travis Bickle's scenes
with Cybill Shepherd before he melts down.
The other Scorsese movie
this pulls heavily from
is 1982's "The King of Comedy."
In that dark comedy, De
Niro plays Rupert Pupkin,
a man so obsessed with becoming a comedian
that he kidnaps his
favorite talk show host
in order to finally get himself on TV.
In "King of Comedy," Pupkin
lives with his mother,
and in "Joker," it appears
Fleck does as well.
His mother is played by Frances Conroy,
who also appeared in the
2004 movie "Catwoman."
Later in the trailer, we see The Joker
greet a TV audience on a set
that looks a lot like the one
from "The King of Comedy,"
and the host of that
show appears to be played
by none other than Robert De Niro.
It also appears that
The Joker is inspiring
a lot of rabid, violent followers.
The twist at the end
of "The King of Comedy"
is that, despite Pupkin landing in prison,
he becomes a beloved,
if infamous, celebrity.
The movie references go
all the way back to 1936.
We see Fleck getting
kicked out of a screening
of the silent Charlie Chaplin
classic "Modern Times"
at a building called Wayne Hall.
The trailer is also partially scored
by a remix of the Chaplin song "Smile."
At one point we hear him say,
The Joker: My mother
always tells me to smile.
Narrator: And let's not forget
one of The Joker's most famous lines
from "The Dark Knight."
The Joker: Let's put a smile on that face.
Narrator: At one point,
we see Arkham Asylum,
which plays an integral role
in the "Batman" universe,
particularly with its villains.
At one point, we see
The Joker greet a child.
This appears to be a young Bruce Wayne.
Could this be leading to The Joker
murdering Wayne's parents?
The murder of Bruce's parents pops up
in almost every "Batman" movie.
In the 1989 "Batman," in which
Jack Nicholson plays The Joker,
The Joker is the one
who commits the crime.
This isn't always the
case, but we're wondering
if that's what this movie is leading to.
Similarly, Arthur's attacked in an alley
just as Bruce Wayne's parents were.
Thomas Wayne, Bruce Wayne's dad,
even appears briefly in this shot on TV.
The Joker's makeup towards the end
is similar to the mask
worn by the protesters
earlier in the trailer,
and he is seen dyeing his hair green,
just like the wig he wears
while working in the streets.
Oh, and we finally get to hear
this new Joker's trademark laugh.
Narrator: Did you notice
anything we didn't?
Let us know in the comments.